en direct sur notre antenne la séance de
questions cribles thématiques
elle est consacrée aujourd'hui à
l'utilisation du taser et du flash ball
par les forces de police c'est brice
hortefeux ministre de l'intérieur qui
vient répondre aux questions des
sénateurs
il faut dire que l'utilisation de ces
deux armes suscite souvent la polémique
en octobre dernier c'est un lycéen âgé
de 16 ans qui avait été touché à un oeil
lors des manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites à montreuil
depuis cet incident dominique voynet
sénatrice maire de la ville a déposé une
proposition de loi qui vise à interdire
l'utilisation du flashball lors des
manifestations en attendant à
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de cette
proposition de loi c'est une autre
sénatrice du groupe communiste cette
fois nicole borvo cohen seat qui a
interpellé au brice hortefeux sur cette
question elle a demandé au ministre un
moratoire sur l'utilisation du flashball
c'est donc un des enjeux de la
discussion de cet après midi que vous
allez pouvoir suivre dans un instant sur
public sénat quant au taser ce pistolet
à impulsion électrique est bien dans son
utilisation est également souvent remise
en cause
en france c'est depuis mai 2010 et la
fusillade qui avait coûté la vie à la
policière municipale aurélie fouquet que
la police municipale et la police
nationale ont le droit d'utiliser ce
pistolet mais alors que la société qui
commercialise le taser donc interdit
assure que le taser ne peut provoquer la
mort est bien lors d'une interpellation
policière à colombes en novembre 2010
est bien un homme était décédé
pour nicole borvo cohen seat sénatrice
du groupe communiste c'est la preuve de
la dangerosité de cette arme
voilà donc pour les enjeux de cette
séance que vous allez pouvoir suivre
tout de suite direction l'hémicycle
bonne science à tous les orateurs aura à
coeur de respecter son temps de parole
et je l'y aiderez éventuellement la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
madame anne marie payet pour le groupe
de l'union centriste avait la parole ma
chère collègue
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues les
violences à l'encontre des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique sont
malheureusement fréquentes
les policiers municipaux au même titre
que les policiers nationaux et les
gendarmes sont devenus des cibles
privilégiées pour des délinquants de
plus en plus violents dans ce contexte
un certain nombre de maires ont souhaité
pour mieux protéger et mieux équipé leur
policiers municipaux les doter de moyens
de force intermédiaire et notamment de
pistolets à impulsion électronique
électrique
si cette décision se comprend elle en a
toutefois inquiéter certains les moyens
de force intermédiaire pour utile soit
ils n'en restent pas moins des armes
dont l' usage doit être très encadrée
est subordonnée à une formation
spécifique
prenant en compte les observations qui
avaient été formulées par le conseil
d'état en 2009
l'armement des agents de police
municipale a fait l'objet d'un nouveau
décret en date du 26 mai 2010 pouvez
vous monsieur le ministre nous préciser
quelles sont les conditions de formation
et d'utilisation des moyens de force
intermédiaire par les polices
municipales
tu remercies vous répondre la parole est
à monsieur brice hortefeux ministre de
l'intérieur de l'outre-mer des
collectivités territoriales et de
l'immigration savent la parole monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame payet
donc d'abord l'équipement des polices
municipales
en pistolet à impulsion électrique est
en flash ball obéit respect que les
principes généraux de l'armement de des
polices municipales ça veut dire que cet
armement d'abord est facultatif
deuxièmement qu'il est conditionnée et
facultatives ses acquis et à la
diligence du maire qui conditionnait il
faut qu'ils aient une convention de
coordination entre les forces de
sécurité et l'état et qu'il est
proportionné et c'est à dire qui est
proportionné aux missions confiées aux
polices municipales et c'est à dire je
veux tenir compte naturellement de la
dangerosité des missions qui leur seront
confiées
alors l'usagé des pistolets à impulsion
électrique est entouré bien évidemment
très fortes garanties d'abord une
formation préalable et qui est délivrée
par 100 nationale la fonction publique
territoriale et une formation
d'entraînement je précise qui est de
deux fois par an ensuite c'est un
système de contrôle chaque arme qui
permet d'assurer à la fois la
traçabilité
et la vérification de son utilisation
concrètement il ya un système
d'enregistrement sonore et une caméra
qui sont associée au viseur et enfin ne
pas va enfin il y à aussi l'exigence
d'un rapport au maire après chaque
utilisation et d'un de ce fait d'un
rapport annuel du maire au préfet et au
procureur de la république enfin des
conditions d'usagé qui sont identiques à
celles prévues pour la police et pour la
gendarmerie nationale je vous précise
pour être le plus complet qu'à ce jour
17 communes ont équipé leur police
municipale de ces armes
madame anne marie payet pour répondre
oui je ne souhaite pas réagir mais le
président parce que les réponses du
ministre ont été suffisamment précises
sur merci qui la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue françois fortassin pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen vous avez la parole
mon cher collègue monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vers ce jour l'utilisation du taser par
les forces de police aurait provoqué la
mort de centaines de personnes sur
l'ensemble des pays qui ont autorisé son
utilisation en france plusieurs
personnes ont récemment trouvé la mort
dans des circonstance laissant
apparaître une responsabilité présumée
de cette arme le dernier décès en date
remonte à longtemps novembre dernier
aujourd'hui encore ses conséquences sur
la santé ne sont pas réellement connu
supposé ne causer aucun risque mortel
sur le fabricant le tazer se banalise de
plus en plus il reste employé dans des
situations qui ne justifie pas toujours
en réalité cette arme qui inflige des
souffrances importantes est utilisée
comme moyen de neutralisation de
rétorsion d'intimidation sur les
personnes ne présentant pas forcément en
danger immédiat de nombreuses forces
police aux états unis utilisent
régulièrement des pistolets électriques
comme moyen de contrainte pour maîtriser
les personnes récalcitrantes au perturbé
époux qui pourtant n'occasionne pas de
trouble sérieux
faut-il rappeler que dans un rapport du
23 novembre 2007 sur le portugal le
comité contre la torture de l'onu a
condamné l'usagé d'équipements des
forces pour les états
le comité s'inquiéter non seulement de
la douleur aiguë constituant une forme
de torture mais aussi les risques
mortels causés par le pistolet qu'il est
pistolet électrique
effectivement il y a dans bien des cas
un choc émotionnel pouvoir entraîner un
arrêt cardiaque dont provoquer la mort
dès lors compte tenu des questions
soulevées par le développement de ces
armes en neutralisation et des cas de
décès répertoriés par des études fiables
nos concitoyens ne comprennent plus
aujourd'hui que l'on généralise leur
emploi sans que le gouvernement ne
prenne davantage en compte la
dangerosité
sans même évoquer les risques de bavures
toujours bien réelle surtout parce que
le taser pose encore de trop nombreuses
questions pourquoi dans ces conditions
ne pas faire le choix de la prudence
laquelle peut en l'occurrence sauver des
vies humaines en suspendant son usage
pour répondre à monsieur gucht ancien la
parole et tout ministre même intérieur
monsieur brice hortefeux la parole mon
cher collègue
oui monsieur le président monsieur
fortassin j'ai compris qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d'interrogations mais
j'ai permettez-moi aussi à mon tour
puisque vous avez droit deux
possibilités vous exprimer après moi
vous poser une question j'ai bien
compris vous étiez réservé sur
l'utilisation de deux césar mais j'ai
pas compris qu'elle était l'alternative
que vous proposez parce que en réalité
c'est assez simple c'est le choix c'est
entre ses larmes les armes à létalité
réalité réduite ou les armes létales
finalement quelle est l'autre
possibilité et je rappelle que
l'utilisation de ces armes c'est ce qui
est indiqué doit se faire en état de
légitime défense alors si l'on prend
l'année 2010 qu'elle a été l'emploi de
ses moyens de force intermédiaire
le flash-ball ya eu 3408 flash ball qui
équipe les polices et qui équipe les
équidés unités de police et de
gendarmerie les plus exposés et en 2010
très exactement les policiers gendarmes
et utiliser le flash-ball à 1480 une et
reprises d'ailleurs c'est moins que
l'année précédente c'était 1600 en 2009
pour le lanceur de balles de défense et
rca plus long distance en clair il ya
3166 lanceurs de balles de défense
quand été utilisé à 491 reprise qui est
plus que les dernières enfin le pistolet
à impulsion électrique on connaît plutôt
dans l'opinion publique et le tazer il
ya quatre mille cinquante et un pistolet
à impulsions électriques équipe les
unités de police et j'en aï les plus
exposés ça a été utilisé en 2010 à 815
reprise c'est moins là aussi qu années
précédentes puisque c'était 907 et je
tiens à souligner parce que ça répond
très exactement à votre interrogation
que l'utilisation de ces armes depuis
2006 depuis 2006 montrent qu'elles ont
été utilisés à 12000 et reprises sur ses
douze mille reprises
oui vous avez raison il y a eu des
accidents des accidents graves mais il a
été limité à 22 heures c'est 22 de
troubles n'ont pas actuellement de venir
mais c'était 22 sur 12000 c'est-à-dire
0,2 pour cent d'incidents supporte seul
puis lorsqu'un seul ministre lorsqu'il y
a des morts entraîné avec des armes
traditionnelles on considère que c'est
une bavure est sacrée incontestablement
une émotion profonde dans l'opinion
publique
lorsqu'il s'agit de flashball on de
taser on a l'impression que c'est moins
grave ce s'il y a quand même 22 morts ça
n'est pas rien alors j'ai envie de vous
dire monsieur le ministre
quelque chose qui existe depuis au moins
la révolution utiliser les cannes avait
requis un don penser que ça le
l'objectif de calmer quand on déversait
l'eau en quantité comme les gros orages
qui permettent de d'évaporer en quelque
sorte les manifestations ça peut avoir
peut-être un effet aussi dissuasif est
beaucoup moins dangereux merci la parole
est maintenant notre collègue antoine le
fait
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire si vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la france comme d'ailleurs la
plupart de ses partenaires européens a
fait le choix d'équiper ses forces de
l'ordre en moyen de force intermédiaire
dit flash ball ou lanceurs de 40 46 et
pistolets à impulsion électrique
l'emploi de ces moyens est bien
évidemment encadré et demeure
subordonnée aux exigences de nécessité
et de proportionnalité
malheureusement des affaires récentes
mettant en cause notamment le flash ball
ont pu légitimement émouvoir nos
concitoyens l'école lesquels pardon
s'intéresse s'interroge sur les règles
qui encadrent l'emploi de ces
équipements même si vous avez déjà en
partie apporter des informations à notre
collègue alain payet pouvez vous
monsieur le ministre nous préciser le
cadre législatif et réglementaire dans
lequel les policiers et les gendarmes
doivent inscrire leurs actions lorsqu'il
utilise les moyens de force
intermédiaire mises à leur disposition
par ailleurs pouvez-vous également
indiqué les procédures de contrôle qui
sont mises en oeuvre
lorsque les problèmes surviennent et si
notamment des contrôles a posteriori sur
les conditions d usage et de ses
équipements sont réalisés je vous
remercie pour répondre à monsieur
antoine lefèvre la parole monsieur brice
hortefeux et l'île de l'intérieur de
l'outre-mer des collectivités
territoriales et de l'immigration avait
la parole monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur antoine le fait bon
arrêtez votre interrogation porte
concrètement sur l'encadrement juridique
de l'usaj de c
moyen de force intermédiaire et leur
évolution aussi puisqu'il faut tenir
compte des retours d'expérience alors
bien évidemment ça s'inscrit dans le
respect de la loi
ça va de soi au travers des exigences du
code pénal et du code de procédure
pénale et notamment concernant la
définition de la légitime défense et de
l'état de nécessité
alors chaque moyen de force
intermédiaire que ce soit les flash ball
ou les pistolets à impulsions
électriques font l'objet d'une
instruction relative à son emploi qui
rappelle le cadre juridique
je vous précise que ces instructions
sont régulièrement mises à jour à la
fois pour tenir compte de l'expérience
de l'évolution des connaissances
médicales qui progresse et des données
techniques scientifiques et donc c'est
très concrètement je vous indique par
exemple que ses instructions et et sont
réactualisées ont été réactualisés en
2009 pour la police et en deux cours de
l'année 2010 pour la gendarmerie alors
sur l'utilisation de ces moyens
bien évidemment il ya une obligation
pour les policiers pour les gendarmes de
rendre compte de l'utilisation de ces
armes que j'ai indiqué il ya quelques il
ya quelques instants
il y à une traçabilité qui est
aujourd'hui une traçabilité est total
puisque l'armée muni d'une puce qui
enregistre tous les paramètres de tir
c'est à dire la date l'heure la durée de
l'impulsion électrique et surtout elle
dispose maintenant d'une caméra qui est
associée au viseur et qui filme donc
l'intervention est donc toutes les
précautions sont prises pour qu'il y ait
donc ainsi une traçabilité totale et que
ça permette d'éviter précisément les
litiges y je précise d'ailleurs pour
être tout à fait complet qu'à ce jour il
n'y a pas eu en france de décès qu'ils
soient délier en tout cas que je
judiciairement qui est été
judiciairement liés à l'utilisation de
ces âmes
je suis le fait vous souhaitiez remercié
le ministre et puis je pense qu'il ya
effectivement un effort à faire pour
davantage communiquer sur sur la
réglementation le bon merci la parole
est maintenant notre collègue charles
gautier pour le groupe socialiste avait
la parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre il n'est
pas question ici de revenir sur le
principe d'un certain armement des
forces de l'ordre il est important
qu'elle faisait en effet les moyens de
se protéger et de prévenir les accidents
de toutes les personnes sur la voie
publique
toutefois plusieurs associations ont
dénoncé avant même les drames récents
sur les nouvelles armes que flash ball
et taser définit comme non létale
pouvait entraîner la mort
le comité de l'organisation des nations
unies contre la torture a qualifié
l'utilisation du taser de traitements
inhumains et dégradants équivalent une
forme de torture
si l'on parle d' arme à létalité à
létalité atténuée
elle n'en demeure pas moins létal est à
zaire sont aujourd'hui considérées comme
des armes de 4e catégorie
quant au flashball il a été démontré que
leur utilisation était extrêmement
imprécises du fait des risques de
déviation des balles même pour un tireur
expérimentés il est donc urgent d'agir
pour rétablir la vérité sur ces armes et
afin d'éviter de au maximum les
accidents larmes idéal n'existe pas mais
tu a cependant fait l'erreur de
considérer ses armes comme non létale
il faut réparer cela est rapidement sur
venice pouvez vous nous dire vos
intentions sur ce point quant aux
polices municipales elles n'ont pas les
mêmes missions que la police nationale
elles doivent rester des polices de
proximité leurs agents doivent être des
agents de tranquillité publique et les
tur gens de légiférer sur la question
pour que cessent les confusions entre
police nationale et police municipale
qui n'ont pas et ne doivent pas avoir
les mêmes prérogatives
aujourd'hui il y ait autant de
situations que deux conventions signées
avec
étalez commune avec une meilleure
répartition des compétences et donc une
disparition des confusions
il y aura ainsi une meilleure
répartition des rôles
sur les dix-huit mille policiers
municipaux 8500 sont armés d'armes de 4e
à 7e catégorie n'y a pas encore eu
d'accident pouvez vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre si vous comptez
uniformiser les textes applicables en la
matière pour répondre à monsieur gautier
la parole est à brice hortefeux ministre
de l'intérieur j'avais la parole
monsieur le ministre le président
monsieur gautier - ya certes un point
sur lequel j'ai déjà un peu répondu la
police municipale gironné en quelques
mois encore une fois je pense très
sincèrement que les moyens de force
intermédiaire sont aujourd'hui peut-être
que cela ils voulurent à la seule
alternative à l' usage de l'armé à feu
encore une fois je précise en situation
de légitime défense
on ne peut pas faire comme si il n'y
avait pas eu 19 policiers gendarmes qui
étaient décédés dans l'exercice de la
fonction j'ai pas du tout c'est ce que
vous avez indiquée d'ailleurs ils sont
pas passés il ya eu des accidents je
vous aime ça enfin les 19 et il ya eu
sur l'année 2010 12800 et 70 policiers
qui ont été blessés 300 officiers temps
à 30 commissaire de police
cet accord qui est naturellement
confrontez vous n'avez d'ailleurs tout à
fait aussi reconnaît à des situations
bien particulières mais il faut
réfléchir de l'alternative à ces armes à
létalité réduite c'est donc l' arme à
feu donc si l'on veut proposer la
suppression de ces
de ces de ses possibilités il faut
savoir que la conséquence c'est
l'utilisation de l'armé à feu
alors si en 2010 il y a eu très
exactement 5 à faire en france qui ont
donné lieu à des enquêtes judiciaire et
administrative
5 ces affaires sont en cours je peux pas
naturellement présager de leurs
conclusions mais s'il y avait faute non
respect du principe de l'etim défense
naturellement des sanctions seront
prises mais pour que les forces de
l'ordre soient respectés bien évidemment
il faut qu'elle soit irréprochable et je
précise aussi mais vous le savez que
certainement les forces les policiers
les gendarmes les forces de sécurité
font certainement partie et des
administrations des sciences
administratives qui sont les corps n'est
plus contrôlée dans notre pays et c'est
tout à fait normal des airs compte tenu
de leurs responsabilités je rappelle
qu'en 2006 par exemple il ya eu 2698
policiers qui ont été sanctionnés pour
non respect et
man gendarmerie un peu plus de 3000 donc
tout ceci pour dire que les précautions
naturellement sont prises et qu'il y a
enfin pour les avez cités là vous avez
cité des rapports des exemples
internationaux je vous précise
d'ailleurs que nous sommes nous mêmes en
discussion avec les ong et notamment
hanister internationale de manière à ce
que la responsable français d'amnesty
international de manière à ce que nous
puissions prendre en compte
éventuellement un certain nombre de
leurs remarques sur les polices
municipales je crois que j'ai à peu près
répondu tout à l'heure monsieur gautier
que charles gautier pour répondre au
ministre écoute et justement c'est sur
les prix ce municipal que mon problème
se fixe et je note que vous n'êtes pas
revenu sur la question qui vous est
clairement posée envisagez-vous une
clarification des missions des polices
municipales par rapport aux polices
nationale et la confusion qui est
entretenue fait courir des risques aux
agents municipaux puisqu'ils sont pris
pour une police d'état et moi je crois
comprendre que dans votre programme de
diminution des effectifs d'état en
permanence qui se trouve être compensée
sur le terrain par justement des
recrutements en nombre à peu près
équivalent des polices locales eh bien
je crains que nous assistions de fait un
transfert de compétences
alors que tous les autres transferts de
compétences dans notre république se
sont faits par le droit mais si la
parole est maintenant madame la
présidente nicole borvo cohen seat pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
sénateurs du parti de bourges avait la
parole le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
répondu 1,62 question alors moi
j'ai interpellé le les gouvernements
successifs vos prédécesseurs et sans
doute vous même je crois sur la
dangerosité du taser x26 et du flash
ball à plusieurs reprises à chaque fois
la réponse qui m'a été fait c'est celle
que vous êtes en train de nous faire
c'est à dire que toutes les garanties
existent formation utilisation limitée
dans certaines circonstances notamment
principalement d'ailleurs la légitime
défense sas et c'était un temps où il
n'y avait pas de morts en france
mais il y en avait par contre de
nombreux aux états unis il nous a été
répondu qu'en france le tazer été moins
fort qu'aux états unis
donc s'il y avait des morts aux etats
unis il y en avait pas il ne pouvait pas
y en avoir en france
or et aujourd'hui il y a eu deux morts à
colombes l'autre à marseille et que
concernant le flash ball a blessé très
grave à montreuil
alors moi les questions je vais peu
j'avais prépa pro b m'était proposé de
vous demander ce que d'autres vous ont
demandé sur qui les utilisent comment
dans quelles circonstances
je vais comme vous avez répondu un
certain nombre de ces questions je vais
vous en cause et une autre puisque la
cnds préconise dans un rapport que le
flash ball ne devrait pas être utilisé
dans les manifestations de rue et donc
je vais vous poser la question est ce
que vous ne pensez pas indispensable
d'empêcher l'utilisation de ces armes
dans les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre lors de manifestations sur la
voie publique
voilà ça c'est clair et net deuxième
question quelle évaluation faites-vous
de la dangerosité puisqu'on nous a dit
qu'elle était le tazer était moins
dangereux qu aux etats unis
ceci dit et peut-être que ce sont des
armes non létales pour quelqu'un qui se
porte parfaitement bien mais comme ce
n'est pas écrit sur la figure des
personnes et biens dans quels cas et un
décharge électrique est effectivement
mortel pour des personnes qui pourraient
avoir quelques insuffisances cardiaques
ou autre merci pour répondre le
président cas par an l'état monsieur
brice hortefeux ministre de l'intérieur
vous avez la parole
oui madame la présidente borvo vous avez
vous évoqué deux situations à marseille
et à colombes
il y a donc comme vous savez une enquête
en cours
moi je ne peux pas me prononcer sur ce
qui ce se qui s'est réellement produit
la procédure judiciaire indiquera
réellement la situation et si j'ai
jamais naturellement s'est confirmée en
tira un certain nombre de leçons
deuxième élément puisque vous avez dit
que j'avais répondu un certain nombre
d'interrogations vous reposez vous me
posez une question est une question
précise c'est l'utilisation de ce type
d'armes à l'occasion des manifestations
vous évoquez j'imagine les saisons que
nous avons eu au cours et au cours de
l'automne donc je vous précise que le
taz est de tazer de fans pistolet à
impulsions électriques et ne doit pas
être utilisé à l'occasion de ces
manifestations à l'occasion de maintien
de l'ordre
sauf naturellement légitime défense donc
mais ça ne doit pas être utilisé dans
d'autres cadres
il ya ensuite évidemment une réalité
c'est que les policiers les gendarmes
sont plus en plus confrontés à des
agrafes agression vous savez certaines
de ces agressions vise à les blessés
dans un certain nombre de cas on peut
même considérer et que l'objectif c'est
même de les tuer et moi j'ai un devoir
comme ministre de l'intérieur c'est
naturellement que ces forces de sécurité
soit et protéger je serai pas dans mon
rôle si je n'avais pas naturellement la
préoccupation constante de savoir
comment protéger ceux qui ont la
responsabilité d'assurer la protection
la tranquillité et la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
moi j'observe que un certain nombre de
voyous n'hésitez n'hésite pas à tendre
des guets-apens et comme vous savez d'un
certain nombre de cas même à utiliser
des armes de guerre est donc encore une
fois il y a aussi une réalité c'est que
souvent les forces de l'ordre quand on
s'en prend des cas extrêmes les forces
de l'ordre sont confrontées à des
personnes en état de démence qui sont d
état de démence temporaire et par
exemple sur l'emploi du pistolet à
impulsions électriques
celui ci est lié dans 54 % des cas et la
nécessité de réduire l'aggressivité
durée la résistance de ces personnes qui
sont sous l'emprise de l'alcool sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants encore une fois
et auto de démence et je vous rappelle
que le taux d'interpellations ski quand
même pas neutres et 2 97% après usage
d'un pistolet à impulsion électrique
merci monsieur mes livres mais mme la
présidente
oui monsieur le ministre je personne ne
va vous dire qu'il faut pas que la
police puisse exercer ses missions
je constate néanmoins que le syndicat
national des policiers municipaux
demandent un moratoire sur l'utilisation
des lasers par les policiers municipaux
donc je constate que y compris dans les
forces de police d'aucuns se posent des
questions sur l'utilisation de ces armes
en l'état actuel de nos connaissances
sur leur dangerosité
ensuite je voudrais évidemment faire une
deuxième obsédé notre observation sait
que de par l'évolution de notre
législation
nous allons avoir de plus en plus
d'opérations disons concernant la
sécurité et l'ordre publics qui seront
des légué à des services de sécurité
privés
alors je voudrais tout de suite vous
demander si on va autoriser des polices
privées à se doter d'armes de 4ème
catégorie puisque vous savez que le
fabricant de tazer par exemple qui est
donc une arme de 4e catégorie en
principe non létales fait de la
publicité à peine déguisée accessible
très facilement pour que tout un chacun
se dote de ce type d'armes
merci mais même le président da par an
les matins notre collègue madame
catherine procaccia pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire vous avez la
parole monsieur quand même merci
monsieur le président vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre les flash ball et
les pistolets à impulsions électriques
constituent une alternative à l'usagé
des armes à feu par les forces de
sécurité mais ces équipements un an
demeurent pas moins des armes et peuvent
être dangereuses toutes les mesures
doivent être prises pour que
l'utilisation de ces équipements se
fasse dans les règles de sécurité
inhérentes à leur emploi et pour éviter
dans la mesure du possible que ne se
produise des cas de blessures
corporelles graves comme ceux dont la
presse et certains de mes collègues ont
pu se faire écho je sais que
vous y êtes attentif monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous interroger sur
la formation des agents qui peuvent être
équipées de ses moyens de force
intermédiaire vous y avez déjà en partie
répondu en répondant à mes collègues
mais j'aimerais savoir cependant s'il y
a une obligation de formation continue
et non pas simplement une formation au
début de l' usage de ces instruments
pouvez vous aussi dans ces formations
nous dira si au delà de la simple
maîtrise juridiques et techniques de
l'emploi de ses moyens des mises en
situation sont prévues ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on leur monde dans quels
cas des policiers ou les forces de
sécurité doivent utiliser comment ils
doivent réagir
des mises en situations donc et enfin
j'aimerais en savoir un peu plus sur les
ventes par internet et par
correspondance
j'ai été sur internet et sur l'un des
sites qui concerte qui concernait le
tazer j'ai vu qu'il était quasiment en
vente libre pour toute personne majeure
et que pour le flash ball
on exigeait simplement un certificat
médical ou un permis de chasse et une
pièce d'identité
je n'ai pas poussé ma conscience
professionnelle je serai en commander un
pour la porter cet après midi mais
j'aimerais savoir c'est le gouvernement
entend encadrer ses ventes sur internet
ou par correspondance
mais pour ma part j'estime que l' usage
de ces armes par les particuliers est
sans doute beaucoup plus dangereux que
par les forces de police
merci ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant aux cieux brice hortefeux
ministre de l'intérieur de la parole
monsieur ministre oui monsieur le
président pardon comme sa première
fauche et des questions cribles je sais
pas si vous pouvez vous demander de
répondre après le temps parole non
monsieur le ministre mais qui sont
rentrés et pas répondu à monsieur
gautier sur un point et j'ai pas
remplies pour dieu femme a d'abord vous
a soulevé un autre point dans son
analyse il nous reste un tout petit peu
de temps mais alors attendez je vais
d'abord est prêt il aurait pas privé
question importante d'accord je réponde
à madame brocas ya d'abord bon pour tous
les équipements que ce soit les
pistolets à impulsion électrique ou les
flash-ball lanceurs de balles de défense
il y à un dispositif de formation
initiale obligatoire qui est prévu et
qui existent pour tous les personnels
qui doivent du tiki ce qu'ils peuvent
utiliser ces équipements et cette
formation doit être validée et elle est
validée par une habilitation qui est une
habilitation naturellement individuelle
qui est pas une habitée billy tation
collective il faut c'est à la fois
discernement le sang froid des
équipements la maîtrise ses équipements
tension plan technique d'ailleurs que
que juridique
alors vous m'interrogez sur le suivi et
le maintien de cette visitation et
précisément est conditionnée par le
suivi d'une formation individuelle qui
est une formation individuelle annuelle
et s'il n'ya pas le respect
naturellement des mesures sont prises on
alors
la deuxième question mal posée celle sur
les questions des ventes par internet
effectivement ça m'a été signalé vous
avez attiré mon attention sur ce point
je vous précise donc que en aucun cas
ces armes ne sont en vente libre partout
et naturellement sur internet et s'il y
a des faits et qui nous sont
communiquées puisque vous avez des
exemples précis je vous remercie de me
signaler parce que naturellement on en
informera et on saisira le parquet alors
simplement si je peux en profiter
puisque j'ai encore quelques secondes
les initiales du bien donc pour monsieur
gautier jeu concernant les polices
municipales ans et elia un décret que
j'ai qui a été pris en mai de cette
année 2010 qu'aligne le dispositif sur
celui de la police enfin police et
gendarmerie nationale dont il y à un
alignement sur ce plan là et madame
borvo par balle va tout d'un coup je
m'en souvenais je sais plus ce que
c'était d'abord vous
je sais plus mais enfin en tout cas ce
que je voulais dire à la haute assemblée
c'est que s'il y en a qui souhaite
constater par eux-mêmes les formations
qui sont dispensés pour l'utilisation de
ce type d'armement naturellement vous
êtes les bienvenus et nous organiserons
avec beaucoup de plaisir la visite de
ses centres de formation
madame prend quelques chiens
cette invitation du ministre allez voir
la formation
et ben moi j'habite monsieur le ministre
et son cabinet allait tout simplement
sur internet a tapé taser au flashball
vous verrez je vous assure que j'ai
failli en ans voire jusqu'à où je
pouvais en commander un sans aucune
difficulté mais j'avais pas envie de
mettre mon numéro de carte de crédit
puisque j'étais pas j'avais pas vraiment
l'intention de m'en de m'en servir vous
tapez anti agression et vous verrez
alors est ce que ce sont des vrais est
ce que ce sont des faux j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas c'est très simple et je
vous dis ce qui m'a surpris c'est quand
on a regardé des conditions c'est de
voir aussi peu de condition
madame borvo parlais tout à l'heure des
polices privées enfin la sécurité mais
si nous particulier on peut s'en acheter
je vois pas pourquoi une police privée
ne pourrait pas le faire
je pense qu'il ya un encadrement comme
d'autres encadrement sur internet qu'il
faudrait vérifier et les sites
paraissait écrit dans un bon français
donc je ne pense même pas que ce soit
les sites étrangers
merci ma chère collègue parole est
maintenant entre collègue madame
dominique voynet pour le groupe
socialiste comme apparenté
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'utilisation des nouvelles
armes de 4e catégorie pistolet à
impulsions électriques et lanceurs de
balles de défense
autorisé en france depuis quelques
années nous interroge aujourd'hui
profondément au moment où ces armes ont
été autorisés on nous expliquait que
permettant d'éviter l'usagé de certains
moyens conventionnels d'intervention de
nos forces de l'ordre et notamment des
armes à feu elle permettrait d'épargner
des vies
elles avaient en commun 17 ans alors
d'être non les
tal je pense que ce terme à rassurer de
façon exagérée
un certain nombre de nos fonctionnaires
de police parce que la réalité est bien
sûr plus complexe
ces armes peuvent exceptionnellement
tuées elles peuvent plus fréquemment
blessés et handicapés durablement
au-delà donc d'une formule séduisante
je crois que nous devons regarder la
réalité chaque mois nous apporte la
preuve de leur dangerosité
a montreuil ville dont je suis maire en
l'espace de 18 mois
deux jeunes hommes ont été gravement
blessés par des tirs de flashball et
maintenant des forces de l'ordre
l'aïe a perdu un oeil l'autre a déjà
subi trois interventions chirurgicales
et en gardera des séquelles durables au
visage dans aucun de ces deux cas
l'attitude des victimes était en cause
en clair les fonctionnaires ne se
trouvait pas en état de légitime défense
ils n'ont pas respecté les consignes
d'emplois dans les deux cas ils ont tiré
au jugé dans le tas dans le cadre de
l'encadrement d'une manifestation sur la
voie publique et pas dans une situation
où ils auraient eu à affronter des
délinquants dangereux pour quelques
jours soit clair l'utilisation de ces
armes ne vais pas seulement en péril les
usagers qui font face elle met aussi en
danger nos propres forces de l'ordre
le rat précision la gravité des
blessures qu'elle occasionne le manque
évident de formation des agents vous
n'avez pas précisé mais je crois que
c'est au maximum deux demi journées de
formation pour ses agents l'extrême
difficulté à respecter dans l'urgence
les conditions très restrictives d'usagé
explose ceux qui les manient à des
risques juridiques et moraux
disproportionnée des deux policiers en
cause dans les affaires de montreuil
l'un a été mis en examen l'autre ne
manquera pas de l'être et cela que nous
souhaitons
combien de temps accepterons-nous que
constituer un soit mise en danger par
l'équipement de ceux qui sont censés les
protéger
combien de blessés combien de morts
faudra-t-il avant qu'on reconnaisse lee
l'adaptation et la dangerosité de ces
armes pour la surveillance des
manifestations de voie publique
l'alternative avez-vous dit aux armes
est alité réduite c'est les armes à feu
moi je considère
que l'alternative pour la surveillance
des manifestations c'est des effectifs
plus nombreux
bien encadrés bien formés il vous
appartient aujourd'hui d'agir limite
entre est drastiquement usage de ce type
d'armes en mettant l'accent sur le
renforcement des effectifs sur la
formation sur l'inscription des forces
de l'ordre dans une logique de proximité
ou encore concernant les polices
municipales et j'en aurai terminé vous
avez insisté sur le fait que le nouveau
décret aligner le rôle des polices
municipales sur celui en ce qui concerne
l'équipement sur les policiers nationaux
moi je considère qu'il s'agit là de
confusion des rôles et des missions qui
ne correspond pas du tout à ce que nous
souhaitons ainsi vendredi soir à
montreuil
c'est la police municipale qui a dû
procéder à la neutralisation trois
malfaiteurs qui avaient pris en otage un
commerçant formule est menacé de violer
son épouse les policiers de la police
nationale sont arrivés 20 minutes plus
tard monsieur le ministre votre minutes
après monsieur le ministre pour répondre
monsieur le président madame voynet
madame la ministre
permettez-moi dû simplement de faire un
premier commentaire puisque vous avez
très largement préjuger des résultats de
l'enquêté et accepter cela de ma part
très modestement et on est condamnés
dans notre pays pour beaucoup moins que
ce que vous venez de dire et c'est un
expert qui vole pas qui vous parle parce
que là vous avez largement porté
atteinte à la présomption enfin en tout
cas aux résultats de l' enquête en
indiquant que inéluctablement
l'un des individus seraient mises en
examen croyez-moi je vous encourageais
très prudente sur ce vocabulaire et
encore une fois je vous dis c'est un
expert qui vous parle dans ce domaine
alors vous évoquez en réalité deux
sujets et enfin plusieurs sujets d'abord
vous évoquez ce qui fait qu tivement
s'est déroulée à montreuil c'était le 8
juil
et lors de l'évacuation d'un squat un
jeune homme a été gravement blessé à
l'oeil par un tir de flash ball et le 14
octobre dernier un lycéen de 16 ans
était blessé au visage par un tir de
lanceur de balles de défense
c'était à l'occasion d'une manifestation
des rois alors pour ces deux affaires
j'ai naturellement demandé immédiatement
une enquête de l'inspection générale des
services indépendamment de l'anc et
l'information judiciaire qui est donc
toujours en cours et pour lequel je me
garde bien de me prononcer je vous le
dis là aussi très directement si ces
enquêtes devaient révéler un suzanne
inappropriés ou des dysfonctionnements
je prendrais bien évidemment un certain
nombre de mesures mais je vous rappelle
comme je les lis je crois monsieur
fortassin et que ces incidents
constituent des cas là plutôt rare mais
puisque de 2006 à 2010 et ce sont 22
incidents 22,2 trop bien sûr mais 22
incidents sur les quelques 12000
utilisation de césar et augé j'ai vu que
vous demandiez à un moratoire voire une
interdiction de l'utilisation de ces
armes alité lité est réduite est
vraiment bien mais encore une fois
et quelle est la proposition alternative
est ce que c'est de dire voilà celle
armes à feu c'est le problème je suis
très attentif à tout ça mais si ce ne
sont pas des armes à létalité à létalité
réduite ça veut dire que ce sont des
armes à létalité non réduite c'est à
dire que dans ces cas-là on aboutit
indirectement had
accepter l'utilisation de ces armes à
feu moi je vous le dit mon objectif
c'est naturellement d'assurer la
protection et la tranquillité et la
sécurité de nos concitoyens mais aussi
d'assurer la protection de ceux qui en
ont la responsabilité et je ne peux pas
les laisser précisément s'envoyant de
prospection sur ministry rapidement
parce que pour permanent et pour madame
borvo jeu indique donc très précisément
que concernant les les
comment s'appelle et la sécurité privée
elles n'ont pas le droit d'utiliser les
armes de 4e catégorie
madame alima boumédiene-thiery
rapidement parce que jouer rapidement
mais ses ministres je ne suis pas
convaincu par ce que que ce soit
montreuil à colombo à marseille est une
réalité il faut savoir dire la vérité
l'assumé ces armes sont mortelles et la
preuve en est c'est qu'elles ont tué
donc je crois que il faut arrêter de
mentir sur cette dangerosité
d'autre part il faut en effet en plus de
la vérité que la justice se fasse on ne
peut pas accepter l'impunité alors je ne
sais pas ce que dira la justice mais en
tout cas il est clair que les
instructions doivent aller jusqu'au bout
on doit connaître la vérité et on doit
et justice doit être prononcée la
sanction doit se faire c'est la
condition sine qua none pour que la
police soit respectée enfin vous
demandez quelle alternative vous le
savez très bien il y a des tas
d'alternatives qui sont d'ailleurs pas
morte elle ne serait ce que par exemple
les canons à eau mais il y a aussi
d'autres alternatives qui sont avant
tout une augmentation des effectifs
nous avons besoin d'effectifs de la
police nationale et ça c'est une réalité
dont toutes les banlieues dans toutes
les deux dans toute la france dans tous
les territoires
nous en avons besoin et aujourd'hui la
réduction des effectifs
et bien ce sont les citoyens qui en sont
victimes merci la parole est maintenant
madame catherine tremblay pour
hop union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président smith face
aux violences de plus en plus fréquentes
et de plus en plus graves auxquels les
représentants des forces de l'ordre
comme malheureusement l'ensemble des
dépositaires de l'autorité publique sont
quotidiennement exposés
la france a choisi ainsi que
l'organisation des nations unies l'a
préconisé d'équiper ses policiers et
gendarmes en moyen de force
intermédiaire au premier rang desquels
figure depuis 1993 le lanceur de balles
de défense floch vol et depuis 2004 le
pistolet à impulsion électrique
la dotation des forces de l'ordre en
équipement alternatif aux armes à feu a
répondu à la volonté d'améliorer la
sécurité de tous les policiers les mises
en cause et les personnes tiers en effet
si l'utilisation de ces équipements
flash ball ou pistolets à impulsion
électrique n'est pas sans risque leur
dangerosité apparaît infiniment moindre
que celle des armes à feu comme le
pistolet automatique dont les agents
sont équipés après avec plusieurs années
de recul quel bilan monsieur le ministre
peut-on tirer aujourd'hui de cette
décision d'équiper nos forces de l'ordre
en moyen de force intermédiaire enfin
vous avez répondu il ya quelques
instants mon collègue antoine lefèvre
que de nombreux dispositifs techniques
ont été mises en oeuvre en vue d'assurer
une véritable traçabilité de
l'utilisation de ces équipements
ce ministre existe-t-il un service
spécifique qui exploite les ces données
en vue d'un travail statistique pouvant
contribuer à l'élaboration d'un bilan
plus détaillé encore merci on répondra
madame tremblay la parole est à monsieur
brice hortefeux ministre de l'intérieur
vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président
madame catherine train bleu bon encore
une fois nous avons fait un choix qui
est un chemin clair que nous assumons
qui est d'équiper nos forces de sécurité
et de lanceurs de balles de défense et
pistolets à impulsion électrique nous
l'avons fait pour éviter précisément que
la seule possibilité d'action de
réaction de légitime défense de la d2f
de nos forces de sécurité se résume au
en clair aux armes à feu
c'est donc une alternative qui a été
ainsi proposé et je les dis vous le
savez nos policiers et nos gendarmes
sont de plus en plus confrontés à des
situations extrêmement difficiles dans
lesquelles on vise à les blessés et même
dans un certain nombre de cas dont
l'objectif était de les tuer je rappelle
par exemple qu'à grenoble le mois de
juillet un policier a eu la vie sauve
miraculeusement puisque vous en souvenez
la balle du délinquant était passé entre
le nez et la lèvre
il avait donc tout frôlé cette partie du
visage
donc les halles usages je vous le dis
très clairement lusage de l' arme à feu
dans nos démocraties doit rester
extrêmement rare ce qu'il car dans notre
pays et doit intervenir que dans les cas
et les circonstances les plus graves et
ses utilisations d' arme à létalité
réduite permettent d'éviter et ses armes
à feu ce sont des moyens de force
intermédiaire qui sont aujourd'hui
indispensables et qui prennent place
entre l' usage de la force physique seul
est précisément de l' usage des armes à
feu il y a naturellement ce que j'ai
évoqué il ya quelques instants tout
c'est traçabilité à la fois grâce à la
caméra à quai dans le viseur et la puce
électronique qui indique le lieu
l'utilisation la durée d'impulsion
s'agissant du pe ou
à distance de projection s'agissant de
ces lanceurs de de flash ball et tous
ces éléments sont pour répondre à votre
interrogation recensé conserver aussi
bien à la direction générale de la
gendarmerie qu'au sein de la direction
générale de la police nationale afin
d'éviter précisément toute polémique le
film luminisme d'hommes simplement pour
remercier monsieur le ministre d'avoir
répondu à mes deux questions merci merci
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
pour cet échange occasion d'éclairer le
sénat la séance
vous venez de suivre en direct la séance
de questions cribles thématiques
consacrées aujourd'hui à l'utilisation
du taser et du flash ball par les forces
de police
face aux inquiétudes des sénateurs brice
hortefeux ministre de l'intérieur a
rappelé que l'utilisation du flash ball
ne devait intervenir qu'en cas de
légitime défense et non lors de
manifestations ou d'opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
le ministre de l'intérieur a également
invité les sénateurs à venir visiter les
centres de formation des forces de
police
le prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
politique et parlementaire c'est à 19h
avec michel grossiord et puis je vous
donne rendez vous ce soir à partir de
22h45
pour suivre en direct l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant à légaliser
l'euthanasie merci de votre fidélité
bonne fin de journée à tous sur public
sénat